先開始吧
然後我說一下
因為有好久沒有跟大家講市場
然後那個最近的話
你們會看到這個整個資本市場上
波動會比較大吧
然後其實美股你上週下跌並沒有跌特別多
我覺得市場影響大家引發很多恐怖情緒的是那個比特幣
就是幣圈市場
可能相對來說跌了更加兇一點
一般來說
你會覺得幣圈可能會領先一下市場
所以大家對這個美股也會比較怕
然後我說一下我的看法
因為最近不光是對於這個市場有一些下跌
然後另外一方面的話
也有很多人其實在談那個AI的bubble
就是AI到底有沒有泡沫
泡沫到一個什麼樣的程度
然後我們現在在一個什麼樣的狀態裡面
然後是不是可以去表述超跌
然後那個是不是要逃跑
然後我覺得這個是大家現在比較關心的一些問題
首先我說一下我放上這個圖
就一直在說AI是一個K-shaped economy
什麼意思呢
就是它很風化
然後好得很好爛得很爛
就是你AI是一個工業革命級別的東西
那你工業革命的過程當中
肯定有人要被淘汰掉
那大部分以前不是說
英國工業革命是洋吃人的故事
AI肯定革命也是機器吃人的故事
我們現在已經看到美國就業生
就是大學畢業生就業率已經
失業率達到9%
這個一個人是一個比較高的數字
這個是不是代表的
背後就是美國經濟變差
有這一方面原因
但是也有很大方面的原因
是現在技術在革命
就是AI是不是一個bubble
是不是一個大的泡沫
我首先說一下我自己個人的看法
我覺得它不是一個泡沫
這是高盛給的一個預期
但這個東西嘛
反正就是做一個參考看一下
他們是覺得AI
每年製造1.5%的efficiency
就是效率增加1.5%的efficiency
那到10年增加完之15
那麼累計的話
就是給到前端的公司的這個
earning大概在8個缺點左右
就大概8萬100
但這是一個非常board lined
就是非常宏觀
或者是不是那麼精確的
一個隨便的估計吧
它用了一些參數
我的discount rate
這是present value
就是現價8億
8億的就是那些公司
有8億的盈利的現價
就是未來10年
但是我們不能否認是說
AI這件事情的
是的確是給效率增加很大
你比方說
你可以現在我們
直接自己在做高頻交易
我自己在做高頻交易的時候
我用的IT就已經很明顯
比方說
我們原來需要好多人
在做的前端
後端
一個人加上AI
就能夠完成
過去好幾個人的工作
就是非常非常輕鬆
當然對於大公司
可能沒有這個效率
它自己內部有些prological
但是對於
我們自己在做
很多開發的時候
這個已經是非常明顯
我相信很多行業
其實都是一樣的
那麼這一輪AI的革命
和2000年的時候
它的本質區別是哪裡
本質區別是
2000年的時候
大部分的企業都沒有入口
就是
它是有完全新的東西
互聯網
或者是高科技是個
完全新的東西
你那時候那些大公司
其實
後面去搭建網頁
都沒有成功
但是
成功的都是
原生長出來的
就相當於是
在高科技裡面
原生長出那些小草
你說
Facebook當時
什麼都沒有
然後這原生長出來的
但是這一輪
和上一輪的區別是
這一輪推動AI革命
它叫並行計算革命
是那些大公司
就是在互聯網革命中間
原生長出來的高科技公司
由它們來推動
而且由它們來引力
所以AI這一輪
為什麼我一直覺得
它沒有泡沫
因為從開始
它就是賺錢的
互聯網
你要從生態
要完全重新建
就相當於
這個生態
什麼都沒有存在
然後出現了互聯網
之後你要把這個
從做投資的這些公司
全部要重建
它沒有賺錢
它的優點當時
沒有很高
使用率當時
在互聯網革命的時候
大概百分之二十萬
現在
我們會看到
整個產業鏈都在缺貨
然後是AI KAPAC造成的
但是同時的話
也是背後
它有那個proactivity
背後有那個引力造成
那就是你們可以簡單的看吧
就是我記得
我之前也講過這個話題
互聯網AI中間
就是我們叫不叫AI
我們叫並行計算中間
並行計算本質上
是把我現在有的這些
數據庫的數據
然後全部能夠給你重新使用錢
通過並行計算的辦法
讓你重新使用錢
那麼在並行計算的這個革命中間
我們看到
兩方面的應用
一方面是UserCase
比方說OpenAI
或者是GPT
或者是
或者是前面的一些
其他市場吧
FSD
那這些使用
其實現在還沒有
真正就是
它在做推理
還沒有真正
能夠看到產生錢
對吧
但是我們看到的
在並行計算
在那個
谷歌的那個廣告推薦
然後在Metal的廣告推薦
那個是給它確定的
已經賺到錢了吧
而且這個投資
收益率相當的
是比較高的
但是投資不光是
增加了它的revenue
就增加它的收益
同時的話
增加它的margin
那麼在很多高科技公司裡面
其實現在我們看到
包括裁員
他也是有
使用更多的AI
讓人變得更加efficient
所以
他把人裁掉
這個事情
本身就是K shape
就是對於他們
就是賺錢
關於對於
被裁掉的人
肯定是往下跑的吧
但是對於這個公司來說
肯定是賺錢的
所以這個革命中間
就我們看到AI
這個革命中間
跟2000年的
本質的區別
是從第一天開始
它現在開始
就在賺錢
CAPEX本身是因為
賺了錢
所以在做繼續的CAPEX
所以我先說一下
這個
一個大宏觀也得看的
就是我不覺得
AI上面有很大的
這個
包括大家在吵
說那個
AUROCO CDS變得很高
我沒有看到
AI上面是一個
2000年級別的泡沫
我們會不會贏來一個泡沫
我覺得很有可能
比方說在明年
很有可能會贏來一個泡沫
但是現在說
它是一個巨大的泡沫
然後泡沫
我對這個觀點
不是很擔心
但是呢
短期裡面
我們一直之前在講的是
這個市場
如果滅死了
4月份的抄底
那麼在今年四季度和明年一季度
市場會給你機會
那給你機會的時候
是以什麼樣的信號
可以給你機會
就是我們叫做
Bad news is good news
之後變成Bad news is bad news
就是當你經濟數據不好的時候
然後市場會開始定價
你要降氣
然後等到市場
看到真正經濟數據差了
降氣沒有用的時候
那麼這個時候
我覺得可能會是有機會
因為經濟數據肯定是會變差的
經濟數據變差的原因
是特朗普瞎加關稅
然後加了關稅以後
又導致通脹上升0.5
這樣的話
美聯儲手臂綁起來0.5
就少加兩次
少降兩次息
它的空間少兩次
然後的話
同時的話
經濟又變差
那這個是
我們叫特朗普
特朗普亂政
中間的一個影響吧
但是這個是確實
已經在經濟層面
我們可以看上
四月份你都看得到
在今年年底是一定會出來
然後再加上
GP和DAMS
就是美國兩黨之間
黨爭
導致它政府關門關了一個月
政府關門關了一個月
它有兩方面
比較惡劣的影響
第一個是經濟數據會不准
就是這個上次我們
還在關門說
就說到這個問題
就是包括你能放PRO
你unemployment data
它都是需要去survey
需要去調研的
那麼這些survey的人
沒有pay
所以它這個數據質量
會很差
即使它公布的話
數據質量會非常差
就9月份我們看到
10月份的數據
肯定是已經很差
然後
連儲
因為這些很差的數據
它再去做決定的時候
就會很困難
因為本身首先
你們會看這個問題
最近市場下跌
也有個原因就是
對於美聯儲降息的
預期在調整
就是美聯儲手上
不會有特別多的子彈
因為今年大家都在
覺得經濟數據差
它要降三次期
我覺得我甚至在
這個時點
我還是覺得12月份
它是會降息的
但是降完以後
它後面有的子彈
會更少
就是你這次12月降了
那你1月份
2月份
就是你明年一季度
二季度怎麼辦呢
你面臨一季度
二季度經濟數據
就會變得更加差
然後你這個時候
你不可能
K-Shape的難處就是
它還有個
往下跑的是經濟
往下跑的是失業
然後很多公司沒有盈利
但是往上的條件
又很明顯
就比方說
美股那些好的公司
它又會很賺錢
然後它估值還是很高
所以你會處於這樣
K-Shape中間
你會處於這樣
兩難的境界
一直比較長的時間
然後那個
所以經濟數據變差
這是
這是一個比較
確定在四季度和
明年會發生的事情
但是
聯儲手上的彈藥
又沒有特別的從中
然後又沒有很清晰
就好像你開車的時候
在下大雨
然後又沒有很清晰的數據
能夠給它很清晰的東西
去執行它去降息的
這些東西
所以我認為是
處於一個什麼狀態的
就是真空
這個第一個真空
就是聯儲政策上
可能因為數據
沒有很清晰
或者因為
自己手上子彈
沒有很多
然後聯儲在貨幣政策上
會有個真空期
這個真空期
要么就是12月份開始
12月份它不降
要么就是
12月份降完以後
明年1、2季度
1、2月份
它也會有個真空期
大家會意識到
它其實沒有餘地
去降很多期的
這個好像
我已經反反覆覆講過
很多次
就是我一直不覺得
聯儲手上子彈是很多的
所以這是美聯儲的真空期
第二方面
美聯儲的真空期
中間還有數據的真空期
這個數據
也都是真的
然後第二個真空期
是Physical Policy
就是財政政策真空期
財政政策真空期
在日本
在美國是一起的
他們是同品的
比如說日本
現在經濟數據也很差
你會看那個
日本現在1.8
這個
它經濟1.8
GDP1.8
然後受到那個
關稅影響
它的Expo被受影響
同時的話
它的Housing在枯蕩
它的房地產在下降
你把日本的房地產
可以印射看一下中國
就是日本的房地產
和股票特別是房地產
它的任何一次上漲
都不會是特別長期的
它人口在縮減
這就是中國房地產
以後的因應者
就是它即使亂印錢
房地產有一些恢復以後
它也不會有長期的
這種大市場
它不會好
因為這個是人口的問題
這個拋開話來說
然後第二
就是美國BBB法案
它通過以後
它政府關了一個月
其實本來
11月份要發出去的退稅
現在要被delay
可能下星期開始
這個星期開始
然後財政能夠採取一些措施
但是你財政的措施
它都有要銷有時間
所以你本來
可能我們預期
3月份的時候
2月份3月份的時候
財政競影響為吃平
或者是辯證
這是本來的預期
那麼現在往後
因為它被國會給block了
然後兩黨之間
可能還會繼續抖
就是現在暫時的方案
到了1月30號再來一次
再搞一次
這個可能也挺大的
所以就是我們又看到的
就是財政政策上面的一個空窗
就是這兩個都是有真空空窗
然後在短期裡面
就是今天晚上
我想想
19號就是明天晚上
明天晚上
那個Navillion
英偉達要去報業績
然後英偉達業績
應該比較預期吧
我覺得這個數據
就是基本上
市場白賽的預期
都基本上在那裡
Beat是肯定的
Bit Beat肯定的
但是Bit Beat之後
沒有Catalyst了
就是沒有那個催化機
市場這些公司的業績
就是因為今年
如果說到K shape的話
網上的都是
好的公司嘛
業績都不錯
然後不停的Beat業績
然後Beat預期
但是這個東西
業績期
就是四季度業績期
差不多要結束了
所以這些都相對來說
比較
怎麼說呢
就比較真空
這些都是在真空的狀態
那在真空的狀態上面
就是市場就會有一些擔心
就比方說
AI會不會泡沫
那現在談比較多的是Oracle
Oracle做一個案例吧
就是Oracle的那個CDS上升
他們的CDS上升
他們的成本肯定要上升
就覺得你槓板太高
然後做了很多的投資
然後AI是不是一個
巨大的泡沫
然後這些討論都會在
隨著你這些真空的時候
會發生
但是我剛剛講過
我不覺得AI是一個泡沫
我覺得像這樣的一些討論
基本上都會給你買落的時機
就是如果
四月份沒有一個機會買的話
其實就是在等經濟數據變差
我們不是一直在等數據變差嗎
等數據變差
然後進去買
我是相對來說比較樂觀
整個情況比較樂觀
就背景是AI並沒有泡沫
Token的需求就是在增加
然後我們現在看到的
真空的Physical Policy
Stimulus的延遲
它還是要出來的
它的法案已經通過了
在美國的法案已經通過了
然後在日本的話
新的手上
別看它跟中國有什麼矛盾
但是
我不知道提了名字
這個騰訊會不會有問題
然後像日本的話
它也是
右派政府也是要出Stimulus
也是要出財政政策
所以你會看到
日本如果也出財政政策的話
那很有可能
就日元對美元還走落
日元對美元走落
還要增加Carry Trade
錢還要到美國去
所以這些東西
就是你會看到
在短期裡面的遲置
但是並沒有看到基本面的表化
就是你稍微長期一點
基本面的表化
甚至你都不知道
它能夠跌多少
就我覺得像S&P的調整
最多是去年7月份
這種級別調整
不是今年4月份的
因為你要是今年
4月份這種級別調整
你需要成為倉位非常擁擠
就我們去年年底的時候
看到倉位很擁擠
倉位擁擠不代表
是說
就是在買股票的人
CTA
和那個Volcan
這些倉位擁擠
包括Volcan
包括你要看到
在CDS上面
在利率市場上
在信用市場上
全面擁擠
就是那個時候
全面所有的倉位
都是一直做
都很擁擠
現在並沒有
等於說
我給你看一下
在這個比特幣
我塗在這個
這個是CDS
其實CDS
今年基本上吃平
你不能說它CDS
變窄了很多
然後
這是Investment Grid
CDS
這個影響
所以我沒有看到
就是
我們可以在
幾個月裡面
reasonable bearish
但是
Fundamentally
要Bareish
你要知道
Bareish是那個
看空
是一個買路的機會
明年
幾個大的動力
我覺得
基本上都還在
就第一個就是
我剛剛講
Physical Policy
就是財政政策
財政政策
中國要繼續推出
中國經濟現在也很長
就是中國
日本
歐洲
美國
這是同頻在推出
現在日本和美國
在同頻
沒有推出
就是在同頻
在等持制
但是在推出之前
所以
這個相反是一個
是一個利好
我覺得
然後第二方面
就是那個
第二方面就是那個
token的需求
就是整體
我們會看到
Hiperscalade
Typex沒有減少
就是包括
你看這次年報
它的需求都沒有減少
然後這次帶動
所有的AI的投資
其實也不光是美國了
就是
Data Center的投資
是在
美國
包括我昨天
看印度的採訪
印度也準備做
然後中國
然後
其實各個國家都在跟進
就是大家感覺到
就是Data Center
因為現在基本上
都是Private
都是那些幾個
大的雲廠在推動
但是大雲廠推動完之後
其實包括中國
也會那樣
這些大公司去推動
就是大家都知道
在AI上的
這一次的軍備競賽
就是我們對於
AI的這個軍備競賽
是工業革命級的
然後是國家
就是
像中美之前的話
是國家
就是競爭性的
要去做這個AI的訓練
所以
很難看到
你們倆說
明年整個需求減少
那
我們現在看到
整個在霸道體裡面
各個方面的需求
就是各個方面的
都在漲價
最近漲了比較兇的
比方說是內存
對吧
在你內存漲完了以後
內存是這個賽道
Memory
內存賽道
那你內存漲完之後
其實我們甚至
會看到去年
覺得不可思議的
像那個英特爾說
他在CPU今年
報年報的時候
都說是缺貨的
就明年
明年年初都是缺貨
就你會看到在
所有方面
GPU缺貨完了
內存缺貨
內存缺貨完了
ASIC都會缺貨
然後連接光模塊會缺貨
然後那個
Networking這些會缺貨
然後Server
去也可能會缺貨
Server CPU
可能都會缺貨
就是這個是
一個全方位的缺貨
就是你的那個
需要
Data Center建立以後
包括後面
可能會
Data Center的建設
這邊都會有需求
因為這個
這個就是
本質上是
供需矛盾
相差太大
我們的需求太大
所以這個也是第二個
我覺得比較樂觀的點
這是我之前也講過的
第三個Financial Deregration
我給一個比較明確的時間
8月底的時候
ESLR的這個規則
鄰廳已經結束了
所以美聯儲的是
6月底的時候
說進入鄰廳
就是要把那個
金融上的區間管給它去掉
然後金融上區間管
那個時候
我給過一個預期
大概4.5萬億吧
就4.5萬億到5萬億左右
就是給市場提供流動性
那這個流動性的提供
相對於QE的話
大概是一個月兩千億
然後一年的話
兩萬四千億
兩萬五千億
然後那個ESLR規則
是銀行結榜
兩千多億的capital
資本金
就是銀行直接
注了兩千億資本金
那麼它對於
然後把那個Ratio給調低了
所以那個
直接可以增加的
不代表大概就是在
我剛講的這個數字
4到5萬億
然後你可以
假設銀行會做風洪
然後
會出來兩萬億到三萬億
但是這兩萬億呢
可能就會在
明年二季度
一季度底的時候出來
因為鄰廳結束以後
美人處給出
確定的執行政策
然後這個一般
會給銀行
六個月到十二個月的
一個adap 就是另一期
所以你在這個過程當中
可以慢慢加自然負代表
然後最終
你可以加個
四萬億到五萬億
然後銀行在這過程中
也可以慢慢去做一些風洪
然後最終的話
可能加兩三萬億
那麼六個月到八個月
六個月吧
最快六個月
然後到八個月
從八月份開始算
就是這個
就是美國明年
financial deregulation
金融去監管
然後特朗普
也不是一個特別
pro-eco的人
所以
第二部分呢
就是能源去監管
現在這個一直在做
就是能源各方面去監管
包括美國的
電力的恢復
能源去監管
所以全方位的
我們看到去監管
也是有很重要的
包括他在Crypto
還也在去監管
對吧
所以整個行業的去監管
然後去監管
導致流動性會寬於
然後這個財政策
然後AI的需求
就是整個AI的需求
本質是AI的盈利
並行計算的盈利
導致AI的投資
然後導致半導體的需求
所以這個我覺得
整體的趨勢
沒有任何的變化
所以在看炒作
Oracle可能要破產
然後Oracle CDS
很高
Oracle有問題
我覺得有點空穴來逢
因為
我做一個不恰當的類比
就是中國房地產
在08年的時候
可能投資收益率是很高
這個現在美國的
這些hyperscale
做的事情有點像
造酒店
就酒店集團自己出錢
然後自己管
然後自己造
造這個東西確實
這個數據中心還是
不設還是有一些難度的
所以他們自己造
然後自己管
然後自己出錢
因為投資收益率高
然後那個
但是資產負債表才擴張
原來是拿自己的自由資本做
自由資本做活動
然後借債做
借債因為投資收益率高
然後大家還願意
現在說你借債成本太高了
CDS給你廠上去
你的labourage太高了
那怎麼辦
下去就去
資產負債表外面做
這個美國以前在那個
CDO上也玩過
中國在房地產上也玩過
最後槓桿加上去
加到最後
我覺得這一輪泡沫
最後在投資上結束
是讓你看到自己的
養老經商都買了他們的債券
不一定是公司擔保的
可能是數據公司獨立開的
然後拿這個優先列後
去劃過的那種戰權
當你的那個投資的 portfolio
hatch fund去買了他的列後級
然後你的養老經買了他優先級
那個時候
我覺得是有泡沫
現在還在表上的
就是08年房地產公司
中國房地產公司
槓桿也很高
也開始變高
後來他們不是
各種各樣表外開始融資了嗎
現在美國這個話還沒開始
但是收益很高的時候
這個開始不會很長時間
他們會開始金融
各方面去監管下農
所以從這個角度來說
我沒有覺得
像Allocore的CES
升上去升到100多個basis point
有特別大的風向
而且Plus
Allocore直接吃掉了TikTok
TikTok這個交易
是我們認為是叫daylight robbery
就是直接白天搶錢的交易
那個中國在國內宣傳
是相當於我把云數據中心
給了美國
但其實的話
TikTok美國就是交給了Allocore
他們把它搶掉了
100多125億
搶了
這個價值是多少
這個價值應該我覺得
2000億吧
Allocore現在值多少錢
所以你可以這樣想
就不能單獨看這個Deo
就是這個Deo聯合在一起
Allocore能夠用它數據來訓練
現在把文字數據
已經全部訓練完了
圖片數據開始訓練差不多
最後訓練的全是圖像數據
就是video的數據
那video全在TikTok裡面
所以這些其實TikTok這些數據
全部給了Allocore
Allocore能夠訓練都在它那裏
然後它手上有的數據
有了TikTok的這個入口
TikTok的入口
可是比YouTube還要大的
然後唯一在互聯網上
能夠有入口的
那剩下除了谷歌以外
現在就剩下TikTok
然後剩下Meta他們
就是真的有入口
就能沒幾家
所以因為它借債多
然後投資了Data Center
去覺得它CDO很高
然後做空
當然做債市可以說
它槓桿高
CDS高
但是Allocore這公司
我覺得沒有什麽特別大的問題
而且它是背後
GOP的大金
它是創的背後的大錢
所以我相對來說是比較樂觀
對整體市場比較樂觀
雖然在短期裏面
就是在
我覺得最多到1月份吧
就1、2月份之前
會有個真空氣
但是你不能說
真空氣到1、2月份
經濟數據在1、2月份
我覺得經濟數據
可能在2、3月份是最差
2、3月份報酬
2月份數據可能是最差
但是市場肯定
不會在經濟數據
到底的時候到底
它一定是提前
一定是提前到底
所以你到底是
12月份還是1月份
這個東西不太好說
所以我也不覺得
這一輪調得會很深
就整體的剛感慮的問題
我剛剛講過
不會調得很深
所以我覺得
如果你們看到現在的話
我個人認為是機會
就是下跌
每次下跌都是機會
然後BTC
BTC你今天早上跌到9萬1了
然後基本上把今年的
漲幅全部給跌出來的
就是跌了9萬1
BTC
我因為在這市場上
做高頻
做交易的
所以BTC
我的判斷
我的感覺是這樣
從10月11號之後
市場流動性確實差了很多
因為其實10月11號之前
流動性就很長
就是已經少了很多的人
那個
本質上呢
BTC不在大周期裡
就是它是一個流動性資產
我們在過去
你可以看一下
10年期利率
當一輪有時候
10年期利率在0.8
最低都是在1以下
現在是在4%
所以整一輪
從去年到現在
都
比特幣都不是大周期資產
它有操縱性
有必然的操縱性
但是它一直受到
去監管的紅利
因為它畢竟是小中資產
去監管紅利
它一直遮到
所以比特幣確實也是漲
但是它不是一個大周期資產
大周期資產
是在AI的token需求
和physical policy
和財政政策
這兩個交集中間的資產
那個
比特幣不是
但是呢
比特幣
不能很看空
因為你從現在這個時點
往後看
那個去監管
還是會對它造成有利的
而且
接下來去監管
是金融去監管
明年2月份是金融去監管
金融去監管
是要直接把錢
帶到市場上來的
就是直接有流動性
會過來的
所以
不是在這個位置上
很看空比特幣的
很看空比特幣
那最後
最後的話
我就提一下
那個十年期美戰
因為我記得
我在4.0的時候
那個
美戰4月4.0的時候
一直說
直接去買sorption
就是看
利率很難突破
實質性的突破4
那麼
現在在4.2
4.1
4.1是4.15
4.1是
剛昨天晚上
稍微掉了一下
但是我在4.1的時候
基本上
把那個sorption
都清藏掉
因為
後面有各方面的不確定性
就是你
如果你年底
我是認為
4.2是一個fair value的話
那麼
其實大部分都已經遲到了
那就
所以我就基本上
把這個國債也清掉
那麼國債的空間
我是認為
後面要繼續去發債
所以呢
這個國債在4.2
還是一個fair value
你們會看得到
4.074的時候
那個
battle cover
在2.4
上週發行
發行債權發完以後
國債又升上去
所以你會看得到
這個十年期的這個
供應點對市場
是會有影響
後面這個影響
就是供應端
不停會有影響
所以大洲期是
既然是財政大洲期
它的那個國債供應
也不太會提了
就是
這個
就純
怎麼說呢
純流動性資產
它並不在大洲期裡
黃金為什麼長那麼多
黃金長那麼多
是因為中國
央行一直在買
中國怕供美國人
打算沒東西用
所以一直在買
它有一個強制的買房
比它避長很多
是因為必然一直在
給房地讓人套利
所以這個東西
都背後有一些原因
但是真正能夠
真正能夠
在這個週期裡面
就是在接下去
比方說一年
這個泡沫性
因為接下去年
我覺得會出泡沫
這個週期裡面
就是
把這個需求
就是token的需求
和supply
所以token的供需
這個中間的
token
供需中間就是擺老體
那這些傢伙
在這裡面這些傢伙
好吧
謝謝大家的時間
你今天先到這裡
然後看你們有什麼問題嗎